[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
incroyable
incroyable mais vrai tel est le titre de
cette émission que vous pourrez regarder
désormais chaque dimanche après le
journal cette émission que j'aurai le
plaisir et l'avantagent de vous
présenter en compagnie de pierre douglas
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui est incroyable mais vrai
eh bien ce sont les faits divers ont pas
les faits divers policiers bien sûr les
faits divers qui nous surprennent les
anciens les fidèles du dimanche sur
antenne 2 se souviennent de cette façon
que j'ai toujours eue d'essayer de
regarder la vie par le petit bout de la
lorgnette et bien ce petit double et
bien ce petit bout de la lorgnette
j'ai tenté de l'agrandir un peu en
compagnie de jacques gérard cornu
d'alain pujol et de toute une équipe
nous avons décidé de vous présenter des
sujets incroyable mais vrai à travers le
monde c'est à dire que nous allons
déborder franchement l'hexagone nous
nous sommes associés pour cela avec un
producteur américain qui s'appelle
monsieur lâm sports monsieur lenzburg as
aussi cette façon de regarder ses
contemporains de la même manière que
nous l'amérique la france ce qui nous
permet puisque nous échangeons nos
émissions de lui se servir de ce que
nous avons filmé et nous d'utiliser les
sujets qu'il nous propose c'est une
je crois que c'est une première en
matière de télévision nous travaillons
et cet état mais vieux rêve pour la
première fois à l'échelon mondial
incroyable mais vrai ce que vous allez
voir dans quelques instants sur vos
écrans
incroyable mais vrai tout en vous
recommandant tout en vous recommandant
de bien vous méfier de ce que vous allez
voir ce qu'ils réalisent ces sujets ce
que vous allez voir
eux seuls peuvent le faire vous je ne
vous conseille pas trop de le tenter
mais regardez plutôt incroyable
[Applaudissements]
le grand canyon du colorado et la
huitième merveille du monde cette faille
immense au pays du western mesures
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres de
longueur et 2 ou 3 dollar
parfois la falaise domine le vide de
plus de 1000 mètres
il a fallu construire une route de 50
kilomètres avant de parvenir au site
choisi par le cascadeur dao à beni hssen
30 ans pour l'incroyable exploit que
nous allons pour montre puis cette piste
de lancement au bout de laquelle se
trouve un tremplin et derrière le
tremplin de witte
premier essai regardez bien dao robinson
va s'arrêter sur une ligne bleue passée
cette ligne c'est le point de non-retour
150 kilomètres à l'heure
la vitesse exigée pour réussir l'exploit
que vous allez voir dans quatre ans
[Musique]
ce chef indien s'appelle mana ce qui
signifie dans sa langue
bonne chance de la chance d'en haut
[Musique]
et c'est numéro d regardez bien cette
voiture vous ne la trouverez pas chez
votre concessionnaire habitude elle a
été spécialement construite pour cette
cascade l'avant a été modifiée pour
empêcher la voiture de piquer du nez
lorsqu'elle quitte le sera car trois
dangers guettent le cas statique danger
numéro 1 c'est la voiture piqué du nez
se retournait dao robinson n'aurait que
trois secondes pour s'éjecter danger
numéro d le cascadeur peut être
littéralement inspiré par le 'trou
d'air' formé à l'arrière de la voiture
ainsi il ne pourrait s'en échapper
danger numéro 3 lorsque la voiture
quitte le sol
le cascadeur ne subit plus l'effet de
gravité son corps libéré comme celui
d'un astronaute dans l'espace
[Musique]
voici david regarder n'est pas sûr
ouais si m
en quelques instants il va tenter la
puce bonne chance
[Musique]
le drapeau vert
tout est ok la voiture s'élance
pour filmer cet exploit il a fallu sept
caméras une sur la rancune sur le bord
du plateau une sur la corniche trois
seront plus bas à gauche dollar en une
dans un hélicoptère ait lieu sur la
piste
maintenant on regarde
[Musique]
m
mon côté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour alourdir
ernest hemingway l'a écrit et nous en
ferons si vous le voulez bien notre
groupe zur en avoir ou pas dao robinson
ma
[Musique]
un croyable mais oui alors évidemment je
vous le répète ne tentez pas cela avec
votre voiture personnelle
à moins que vous vouliez à tout prix
résoudre le chômage partiel chez les
constructeurs automobiles mais croyez
bien que c'est vraiment impossible à
faire c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que nous
vous l'avons proposé comme ça m'inspire
quand même une double réflexion jacques
c'est que d'abord c'est un moyen quand
même efficace lorsque l'on cherche à
convaincre son mari ou sa femme qu'on
veut changer de voiture oui alors il ya
la deuxième réflexion découle de la
première c'est je crois qu'il est
absolument indispensable d'apprendre à
sauter en marche il faut absolument
sauter en marche savoir sauter en marche
avant de se précipiter dans le vide
c'est ce que d'ailleurs monsieur chirac
se tue à dire à michel devrait qui ne
veut pas comprendre très exactement
incroyable
en direct aujourd'hui sur le plateau
d'incroyable mais vrai un personnage que
nous allons découvrir
on le répète souvent mais celui là est
authentique c'est l'homme le plus fort
du monde vient de glace alors le sais
pas moi c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
rassurez vous façon ça ne se serait pas
l'homme le plus fort du monde va tout de
suite arriver sur ce plateau
il s'appelle et iñaki perurena c'est un
agriculteur de 24 ans il pèse 117 kg et
vous allez tout de suite lui décerner
rien qu'en le voyant
il est là un grand bravo
[Musique]
alors ne pas interviewer les unia qui
perurena parce qu'ils ne parlent pas
français vous ne parlait pas français
mais c'est ce qu'il a dit jacques qu'il
ne parle pas français d'accord oui vous
avez bien 24 ans oui il a 24 ans et vous
êtes agriculteur il est agriculteur
alors vous êtes originaire d'un petit
village d'une petite commune espagnole
qui s'appelle laisse vous allez nous
faire la démonstration des jeux de la
force séverine et oui les idées dont il
est espagnol où il dépasse c'est ça la
question
mais non là je faisais pas je ne peux
pas vous répondre parce que je ne tiens
pas être plastiques et dans la semaine
voyez vous est ce que je voudrais
préciser c'est que cet homme que nous
avons devant nous et le champion du
monde de jeux olympiques qui sont les
jeux de la force passe oui car il est
bien entendu jacques si naturellement
iñaki perurena participer aux jeux
olympiques de los angeles en 1984 par
exemple avec les possibilités physiques
et musculaires qu'il a je crois que tous
les records d'haltérophilie sauterait
seraient pulvérisées à l'effet il nous a
fallu voyez un chariot pour amener ici
regardez bien deux blocs de pierre voici
une boule qui pèse 125 kg c'est une
boule de marbre sienne 100 kg 100 kg
vous voyez vous parlait très bien
français mais ça je dois dire
et voici un autre bloc de pierre c'est
un cylindre qui faisait 200 kg 200 kg un
cylindre en granit et pour vous prouver
que nous ne trichons pas il y a là une
balance et après votre tour je vous
demanderai votre démonstration de bien
vouloir redéposer ces objets sur cette
balance que nous avons réussi à mener à
grands frais je vais traduire ce que
vous avez dit jacques à noter que vous
aurez terminé votre tour nous allons
peser n'est ce pas la boule et le sida
de manière que l'on constate que vous
n'avez pas brillé pas vous comprendre
quand vous
avoir fini démonstration vous posez
pierre sueur balance compris et vous m
avec balance bien je n'ai pas d'histoire
y'a pas de quoi vous voulez commencer
avant la pause il n'y avait peut-être
commencer par se trouver la balance
je fonds viendront ça c'est les ordres
ça passe par le haut 100 kg on peut
applaudir la balance
[Applaudissements]
des chaussures renforcer jacques non
mais j'ai très peur pour descendre d'un
étage 200 kg regardez attentivement la
balance
veuillez vérifier 200 kids
[Applaudissements]
je
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tous les agriculteurs étaient aussi
puissants n'aurait pas de problème en
france agen grands comme manifestation
certainement deuxième démonstration
qu'on roule
chut
je
d'un seul bas
[Musique]
le voilà iñaki perurena capitaux mais
y'a de quoi souffler
je
rien que ça j'en ai pour trois semaines
à voir m comme ça
poids de la boule 100 kg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci bravo
incroyable
c'est ce que l'on peut appeler un
véritable tour de force incroyable mais
vrai traversons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a traversé c'est véritablement ce que
l'on peut appeler un tour de force
incroyable mais vrai ce n'est pas
seulement un exploit sportif pas
seulement une cascade
incroyable mais vrai c'est aussi
certaines particularités certains
personnages singuliers comme nous en
avons montré autrefois dans la lorgnette
tout comme vous avez pu en apercevoir
dans l'émission de jacques gérard cornu
alain pujol voir nous allons traverser
la manche la manche est par définition
le pays où il y a le plus de gens
singulier nous allons partir pour un
coin de la campagne anglaise et je
voulais se découvrir en même temps que
nous une dame
pas tout à fait comme les autres quelque
part dans la campagne anglaise
un cottage comme il y en a tant en
angleterre une anglaise comme il y en
attendant les cottage anglais mise crise
elle a 60 ans c'est une anglaise une
anglaise à ceci près à ceci prés disait
qu'elle possède les ongles les plus
longs du monde
nice 17 les couper quand j'avais 3 ans
autant j'avais une amie blanc qui avait
vu le film l'ange plus et elle m'avait
dit que c'était la mort d'avoir les
hommes l'ont emprunté les drogues et
vous les avez laissé pousser oui je les
ai laissés pousser comme ça mettez
l'accent à l'école il n'aimait pas du
tout l'idée il ne voulait pas me donner
de blues je ne comprends pas quel est
leur affaire de la longueur heureusement
il a perdu dans ce coeur la maîtrise me
disais que je ferais mieux de tremper
mon ongle dans leur grille est plutôt
que mon plus grand nombre mes parents
étaient très gentils avec moi ma mère
avait peur que je la griffe mais mon
papa me protéger de mana et comme là
cela devient très bien tout le monde
trouvait que c'était très joli
votre mari n'a rien non pas du tout il
dit que cette fouille pratique comme ça
le gratuit dans le doubs et en public
en public il ya des gens qui on les
trouve très horrible mais souvent ça me
permet d'entrer en contact avec la
question sur mes hommes non non au
contraire pourrait se mesurer vos ongles
mais je ne peux rien vous redresser je
suis curieuse je ne sais pas peut-être
une quinzaine de centimètres
mais n'a y pas de mener vue vrai cm
c'était un an ils ont dû pousser encore
depuis le dernier à fois faire la
vaisselle literie
oui je peux la faire elle essuyé aussi
et même nettoyé le cas ce mardi les
petites qu'on chérit qui se coince dans
le fort et je peux même plus coudre et
faire toutes les choses quotidiennes
dans la vie vous avez des problèmes je
n'ai aucun problème et je vous dirais
même monsieur madame pardon que c'est
très facile pour se coiffer le matin
alors mr reste du monde
est ce qu'il y avait sur une tous les
matins avec vous je ne peux pas vous le
tour mais le soir quand la lumière est
éteinte il arrive quelquefois que mon
mari est parti il ya une quinzaine à
votre main droite cassée on emporte il
peut mais l'été c'est le double eh bien
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais une main
plus moins vite que l'europe ne vous
dois bien non je crois que ce sont mes
gants qui vont réformer la mise et pour
mettre une école anglaise est pas un
problème et bus non ça n'est pas
difficile je met des gants de boxe
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas eu le temps de faire
appel à des interprètes officiel mais la
traduction de la conversation est en
partie exact et vous avez reconnu bien
évidemment sous la voix de léon zitrone
son double pierre douglas
si vous voulez avoir les ongles de la
même longueur que cette anglaise il faut
donc commencer à l'âge de 13 ans et ne
pas vous les couper jusqu'à l'âge de
soixante soyons gentils
autre sujet et cette fois-ci revenons
sur cette bonne terre de france bien sûr
la france a elle aussi besoin de records
nous sommes capables d'être les premiers
quelque part vous allez voir que nos
petits français cocorico enchères léon
que nos petits français sont capables de
battre un record mondial
suivez-nous quelque part là bas dans le
midi où tout est possible avec l'aca
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
il est 15 heures 15
et nous sommes maintenant à quelle
hauteur michel nous sommes aux alentours
de 6 mètres mais nous avons un problème
on a peur de manquer de chou au monde
des choux et pourtant on en avait pas eu
beaucoup parce qu'il en resterait mais
on a un problème on va essayer de
gratter les fonds de tiroir pour poirier
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait non madame
fabriquer une suite on va essayer d'en
fabriquer avant l'heure pour soutenir
les délires il manque de m pratique
[Applaudissements]
il faut combien de chou comme cela pour
confectionner un gâteau aussi
gigantesque environ dix mille 300
chevaux oui ça veut dire combien de
farine combien de hausse en 4 avec la
farine
plus de 2000 e le maintien qui redevient
de la crème pâtissière 200 litres de
crème pâtissière programme dense et
chaude voilà vous travaillé sur la
préparation de ce bateau depuis combien
de temps
qu'est ce jour à raison de trois heures
par jour en même temps qu'eux ont fait
le travail pour le magasin comprend des
3 0 pour faire si je trouve en zone 2
milliards dont environ
au nom de la loi je vous déclare unis
par les liens du mariage
vous avez bien sûr prévu un gâteau de
mariage monsieur comment est il
monsieur même maillot je suis ravi de se
marièrent jaune peu exceptionnel je vous
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur et dans
votre corbeille de mariée je vous mets
le plus grand gâteau du monde
monsieur le maire ça tient à quoi ce
bout de l'exploit ce goût du défi dans
votre commune ce goût du défi la commune
je pense que au début c'est parti c'est
le l'union sportive de la ville de trets
ce qui au cours d'une réunion amicale
dont faisait partie de charcutiers
bouchers de presse ait lieu pâtissiers
ont décidé de lancer un défi à la plus
grande saucisse aux plus grands 60 et au
plus grand gâteau s'amusait beaucoup de
monde et le jour de la première
manifestation auquel viol ou tentative
de record nous avons rue un monde fou et
devant le succès remporté nous avons
reçu des lettres même d'amérique en
disant qu'ils voulaient relever le défi
là
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
il est exactement 17 heures cela fait 10
heures que lui seul arnaque travail sur
ce gâteau il est terminé
ici m barberousse puisieux m faites
votre travail
[Musique]
cette même 96 cette bête 96 aventure
record absolu voiture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
allons
il faut donner l'explication dire
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas aller plus
haut encore i masculine peut dire
pourquoi ne sont plus sévères
je pense je pense que si le gymnase
n'avait pas été limité à 8 mai monsieur
neufs devraient aller beaucoup plus haut
[Musique]
incroyable voilà c'est ça la france
nous détenons enfin un record du monde
nous ne sommes peut-être pas capable
d'envoyer une fusée dans l'atmosphère
mais avec notre gâteau nous l'avons mis
dans le baba au reste de l'humanité
dans quelques jours ce sera noël noël
c'est aussi une fête incroyable c'est la
semaine du bonheur pour les enfants
et puis pour les grands aussi car on a
véritablement autant de plaisir à
commenter les cadeaux père noël
[Musique]
pardon qu'à voir la joie de nos enfants
lorsqu il déplie les paquets et bien il
y a quelqu'un de fantastique à grenoble
qui à longueur d'année est un peu le
père noël des enfants les enfants de
grenoble ont vraiment de la chance parce
qu'il y à là bas à grenoble un jouet
incroyable mais vrai il ya mille
manières de distraire au pic alors même
que plus grand et joue il n'y a pas
d'école
étienne un petit écolier
comme tous les autres oui comme tous les
autres enfin presque
si vous n'habitez pas grenoble a bien
n'hésitez pas à vous y rendre
une fois sur place demandez aux premiers
pas sont venus même une scic turc
portugais l'écurie de monsieur pierre
monnier une écurie de course pas comme
les autres ici 43 petits grenoblois de 3
18 ans qu'on soir dessine fabrique
carrosse police et met au point de
véritables mini bolides qui atteindront
200 à l'heure
le
là
soit avec le
[Musique]
et
vous
[Musique]
qui conçoit qui dessine qui fabrique qui
karosky police et qui met au point de
véritables minimaux leed qui atteindront
2 100 kilomètres à l'heure et ainsi
chaque samedi
on se rend sur la piste
et c'est là nous le dire aux confidences
c'est là où les enfants de commencer à
rêver mais arrivé pour de vrai voici
quelques pointes de vitesse déjà
contrôler en toute sécurité
trois ans et demi cinquante kilomètres à
l'heure un pilote de 10 ans à 110
kilomètres à l'heure un pilote de 15 ans
190 kilomètres à l'heure
[Musique]
veinard en somme
c'est le rêve de tous les petits garçons
france et même des papas
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux
et bien ce petit garçon s'appelle
etienne et tue à vous en veux tu
descendre de la voiture est tiède et je
vais demander à ce père noël grenoblois
qui a eu cette idée fantastique pour les
enfants de bien vouloir entrer sur le
plateau d'un progrès vrai monsieur je
viens gagner hier
pierre mesa comme un dossier comment
avez-vous eu l'idée de cette de ce
divertissement extraordinaire vous savez
il faut déjà émis des automobiles
il faut l'aimer très fort et je crois
que depuis quarante-sept j'aime
l'automobile parce que j'ai vu un grand
prix de france en 47 allusion et c'est à
la suite de ça que j'aurais voulu être
pilote automobile
mais évidemment ça c'est plus compliqué
alors je me suis tourné vers les enfants
et j'ai commencé une voiture pour mon
fils et à la suite de cette première
voiture j'ai dit pourquoi pas en faire
d'autres et surtout les fabriquer avec
eux c'est à dire monter une école qui a
pour but le développement du travail
manuel est la conduite automobile chez
l'enfant
alors dites donc grâce à vous c'est un
peu le paradis c'est fantastique pour
toi parce que si je comprends bien
etienne tué le petit garçon le plus vite
du monde à quelle vitesse va tu 110 110
kilomètres à l'heure tu as passé
tu n'as pas ton permet de conduire mais
tu as ta licence de coureurs ben ça
c'est formidable
combien avez vous de pilotes quand votre
pied et bien maintenant j'ai quarante
trois enfants mais enfin comme pilote
j'en ai encore une quinzaine et au
printemps si vous voulez nous allons
tout s'est fait reconduire surtout les
derniers rentrer parce que de plus en
plus nous prenons d'ampleur et je crois
que avec les six nouvelles voitures que
nous essayons de construire pour le
printemps on pourra satisfaire tout le
monde
alors une question ça coûte très cher
pour rentrer dans votre club
oh non c'est pas cher je trouve que
c'est pas plus cher qu'une saison de ski
c'est 150 francs par mois sur toute
l'année
et évidemment ça comprend les assurances
les assurances au niveau de l'atelier au
niveau du pilotage et si vous voulez
tout la fourniture du matériel pour
réaliser ces voitures dites-moi est-ce
que c'est un peu une bonne initiative
qu'on pourrait étendre à la france
entière ça parce que finalement si vous
divisez 150 francs par mois par quatre
jeudis 4 dimanche 4 mercredi pardon et
quatre dimanche ça rien pas même un ca
fait le prix d'une place de cinéma
et bien moi j'ai voulu avoir l'avis d'un
spécialiste qui a regardé ce document
avec un oeil émerveillé et il faut dire
que cette voiture c'est une ligier
reproduit fidèlement aux deux tiers
oui c'est un peuple akan alors dit
vivier nous appelons aujourd'hui
sauf que
[Musique]
guy qu'est ce que tu penses de sers bien
je dois dire que pour cette incroyable
mais et je crois que cette initiative de
ta vie grenier et et monnier est une
initiative merveilleuse parce que je
crois pour les jeunes pour etienne pour
tous les tous ces jeunes qui vibre pour
l'automobile en général parce que tous
les jeunes aiment l'automobile c'est
vrai je crois qu'il faudrait continuer
ses expériences les soutenir surtout
parce que je crois que pour eux c'est
une motivation extraordinaire et pendant
qui le fabrique de leurs mains des
engins comme ça je crois que c'est pour
eux très utile pour pour toute leur vie
parce que ça devient après un métier ça
devient une passion ça devient et je
crois que c'est la meilleure motivation
que notre ami a pu leur offrir
eh bien quelle est votre plus jeune
pilote j'ai eu des phénomènes de 3 ans 3
ans et demi et trois ans et demi on
considère que au maximum il pousse à 50
mais vous savez pourrait aller plus loin
mais ils sont ils sont prudents ils
après midi ils sont prudents parce
qu'ils savent la valeur de ce qu'ils ont
entre les mains puisqu'ils l'ont
construit c'est sa vie une chose aussi
peut-être y at-il dans ce petit etienne
un futur pilote devrait formule 1 mais
pourquoi pas je crois que si etienne
continue il faut qu'il percevait remet
il faut il faut surtout qu'ils
continuent aussi à bien connaître la
mécanique parce que je crois que ce sera
important pour lui pour twitter il la
connaît bien la mécanique puisque cette
voiture et tiennent aussi non seulement
la pilote mais il a aidé à la construire
bravo vous êtes merveilleux je vous
remercie
sept migrants
pour les enfants incroyable vous la
gardez un petit moment parce que j'ai
l'impression que dès l'émission terminée
je ne pourrais pas résisté au plaisir de
rentrer dedans
si je veux incroyable mais vrai ce n'est
pas seulement
l'exploit sportif ce n'est pas seulement
la cascade c'est parfois simplement un
être humain est un être humain peut être
incroyable mais vrai nous allons aller à
nice vous connaissez nice on y passe
on y va en vacances mais nous a nice
nous avons rencontré un personnage
étonnant
incroyable mais vrai à nice cette
vieille catane la belle époque qui lie
les jambes écartées sur le bd
méditerranéen en guettant les trois
derniers sous 2 millions de vieilles
gens qui viennent attendre la mort au
soleil fans et de la promenade des
anglais
c'était nice ce grand dortoir dans la
mort que nous avons rencontré monsieur
polony messieurs paul audience et un
tailleur arménien parce qu'un français
il dispose de 3 francs par jour pour ses
menus plaisirs
alors la vie ne serait pas très gai bien
sûr si monsieur paul audiences chaque
nuit d'aller faire les poubelles la
capitale méditerranéenne
il ramasse tout ce qu'il peut le vieux
bouts de tissus les paillettes fans et
des rues band est un des lieux clipse
des boutons les capsules de bouteilles
et avec ses trois fois rien
monsieur paul awdian occupe ses heures
de loisirs a confectionné des costumes
de carnaval auquel il n'a jamais
participé
[Musique]
chaque jour monsieur paul audio se
déguisent
[Rires]
[Musique]
il s'amuse faut le dire
il s'amuse à faire rire les petites
vieilles
[Musique]
une
et chaque jour grâce à lui c'est un peu
le carnaval de rio dans cette maison
mais bon
il
[Musique]
on les plus raisonnables pense que
monsieur pologne en est peut-être un peu
fou eh bien ça n'est pas vrai monsieur
peut le dire n'est pas fou monsieur paul
awdian est un artiste un vrai un haut
rang c'est un cousin éloigné du facteur
cheval
[Musique]
nous
et tour à tour monsieur paul awdian
paraît en grand mogol à mufti emprunt ce
tartare en magicien
voilà j'ai trouvé le mot qui me manquait
en somme paulo dian c'est le magicien
d'oz
[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
vous
mon dieu si j'arrive un jour où paradis
voudrais que vous dernier en place à la
gauche de monsieur paul audience je suis
sûr que je ne m'engagerai pas pour
l'éternité
[Musique]
j'avais invité monsieur paul audio mais
monsieur paul awdian est souffrant alors
si vous le permettez un petit message
personnel monsieur paul awdian pour
votre talent votre sens de la poésie
rétablissez vous très très vite et je
vous souhaite du fond du coeur et je
crois que tous ceux qui sont dans la
salle aussi le pense a très très heureux
de rennes bravo
[Musique]
incroyable
alors là incroyable mais vrai je vous
connais bien vous les français
est ce que vous allez voir va vous
stupéfié savait pas pensable dans notre
payer mon cher pierre et moi je me
demande d'ailleurs si c'est vrai dire
qu'on a préparé l'émission 100 mais là
c'est le premier set dernier sujet de
l'émission mais c'est le premier sujet
je me pose vraiment la question est ce
que c'est vrai parce que c'est bien
c'est tellement incroyable que ça ne
paraît pas eh bien je certifie que ce
document vous allez voir est authentique
ce personnage est absolument
invraisemblable on peut s'attendre à
tout mais gagner sa vie en faisant ce
que fait ce monsieur
ça ne s'invente pas et je vous défie le
faire d'ailleurs entre nous jose il
conseille pas nobel avait prévu toutes
les utilisations de son invention tout
sauf une
john harding lui n'a rien inventé même
pas la poudre
sinon une autre façon de se servir des
explosifs lorsqu'il était son drapeau
harding travaillait dans le gym le génie
militaire vous voyez la nuance c'est à
dire qu'il était instructeur en
démolition ce qui l'amena à faire des
expériences plutôt bruyante
une fois libéré harding se dit qu'il
pourrait peut-être faire son trou dans
la vie civile grâce à son talent
explosif
tout d'abord il construisit un mannequin
de la m 80 exactement à sa taille
puis un cercueil après quoi il plaça le
mannequin dans le cercueil avec une
charge de dynamite pour faire sauter le
tout une charge de dynamite composé à
exactement de deux pains de dynamite à
60% de nitroglycérine
de quoi faire exploser l'appartement de
votre voisin pour eux qu'ils ne
partagent pas vos opinions politiques
et un beau jour ardennes se substitua au
mannequin il perdit connaissance pendant
quatre ou cinq minutes après l'explosion
il éprouve à des sensations très bizarre
et ses copains lui dire qu'il n'aimerait
pas du tout faire ce qu'il venait de
faire aujourd'hui
harding se fait sauter régulièrement
quatre fois par semaine mais sans la
coopération du service de réanimation
des pompiers ils connaîtraient de très
sérieux ennuis suivi d'un enterrement
pourquoi john harding fait-il soula tout
simplement parce que c'est la meilleure
façon qu'ils aient trouvé au monde de se
recycler après son séjour prolongé à
l'armée harding clos hermétiquement ses
oreilles car la dynamite et très bruyant
doux l'avez peut-être remarqué trois
protection mieux qu'une la dernière
cigarette
peut-être celle du condamné et devant
une foule enthousiaste les petites
villes américaines
hardin va se livrer à son numéro favori
les pompiers sont sur le qui vive car si
ils n'interviennent pas dans les
quarante secondes qui ont suivi
l'explosion
hardin partira pour un monde meilleur en
effet l'explosion chassant violemment
l'ère des poumons
monsieur harding perd connaissance et
c'est la fin
[Musique]
nous sommes une petite vie tranquille
sans écrit encore une fois cela
[Musique]
j'adore
et
je
les vous mon 110 morts il ya je trouve
que monsieur harbin est un sauteur on
s'éclate
je ne voudrais pas mon cher pierre jouer
les chauvins mais quand même il me
semble que les français ont trouvé un
moyen plus agréable et moins bruyants de
s'envoyer en l'air ou alors je plains
les voisins et bien c'est sûr ce bouquet
de feux d'artifice que nous allons clore
notre première incroyable mais vrai et
je signale à tous ceux qui ont regardé
cette émission que nous faisons appel à
eux si vous connaissez un personnage une
situation incroyable mais vrai n'hésitez
pas à nous écrire à incroyable mais vrai
théâtre de lempire paris et je signale
d'autres par nos confrères journalistes
de la presse écrite que s'ils veulent
s'essayer que s'ils connaissent un sujet
nous tenons à leur disposition tous les
moyens pour aller le film est incroyable
mais vrai incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]